euh on va passer au boss du jour on va
revenir sur cette proposition du maire
de Marignan euh Marignan 1515 oh oh fait
énormément réagir bravo il soit équiper
c'est la seule date que je connais hein
bien sûr je connais 1515 et 1900 euh
2006 c'est quoi 2006 le pire jour de ma
vie c'est quoi le P le jour où j'ai
rencontré Gill
Verdez euh les chér souhait équiper tout
le personnel des écoles de sa ville de
bomb la crimogène objectif assurer leur
sécurité à l'ORS où ils sont devenus des
cibles bien entendu je suis d'accord
avec lui bien entendu Verdez ne sera pas
d'accord avec lui bien entendu un moment
il faut penser au personnel des écoles
après voilà moi je suis d'accord avec le
maire de Marignane Gill Verdez bien
entendu ne l'est pas et c'est bien
Gilles parce que ça fera un débat et le
maître chien lui il est pas d'accord
parce quement ça
enlève dit ben écoutez pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas équiper les professeurs des
des écoles de cette bombe lacrymogène je
pense que la sécurité des enseignants
c'est quelque chose de de très très très
sérieux surtout à l'heure actuelle où où
il y a des agressions et surtout il y a
plus de la moitié des enseignants qui
ont demandé à en être équipé alors qui
est d'accord Jean-Michel bah évidemment
bien sûr les enseignes
son les enseignons pas vocation à être
des tondus des moutons qui sont tondus
vivants comme ça à partir moment ils
font régulièrement l'occasion
d'agression de la part des élèves ou de
la part de gens qui rentrent de façon
indue dans le lyé il est évident qu'il
faut leur donner tous les moyens si on
peut pas les défendre on peut pas
empêcher les gens de rentrer dans le
lycée d'empêcher les gens et moi je ser
même pour donner certaines bomb lacrimau
à certains élèves aussi les élèves qui
sont notamment les jeunes filles si
NOTAM les jeill son AG qui sont agressés
qui sonqués qui font l'ICE de
violence c'est illégal rien à [__]
faut changer les lois c'est tout donc
moi je suis pour que les
gens pas don la parole pas don la parole
je ou mon ami bah oui quand vous serez
mon ami vous parlerez moi je suis pas je
suis pas du côté de la loi je suis du
côté de la sécurité
pour a plein de professeurs m'ont dit
qu'il ne voul pas avoir
B é d' l'idéologie parce que comme ça
vient me de div droite il ve
pas il parce disent que c'est un pement
sur une jambe de bois qu'on règle pas
les
problèm va avirour intéressant
contraement Ré faux problème évidemment
donner les moyens au professeurs de se
défendre c'est intéressant mais il prend
l'exemple de Dominique Bernard Dominique
Bernard et Samuel pati ils sont morts à
cause de quoi à cause du fondamentalisme
islamiste face à un non mais face à un
terroriste il faut dire la vérité tu
fais quoi avec une bombe Lacrimo moi je
suis je suis d'accord pour équiper pour
équiper les professeurs mais le problème
est bien plus profond devant les non
mais je suis c'est une par est pour il
est pour aller dans sens devant les
lieux devant les lieux de C mais il
comprend rien lui il comprend Ren com ta
gueule
l'ancien
elle est pas elle est mal
préparé pardon à lui pardon quand même
as quelque chose d'intéressant à dire
oui bien sûr devantant
les les gars on est pas la on
pasassem devant les lieux de culte il y
a l'armée qui protège les fidèles qui
viennent prier devant les synagogues les
mosquées les églises dans la République
le lieu de culte c'est l'école il
devrait également y avoir l'armée mettre
les for
de TR chiant ou non mais parce que non
parce que vous prenez les problèmes à
l'envers à chaque fois si vous si vous
voulez mettre des bombes lacrimau dans
danses dans ces collèges dans ses lycées
c'est qu'il y a des problèmes c'est que
les écoles vous pensez vraiment qu'avec
des enfants à problèm vous allez les
gazer mais c'est s y a un problème un
problème avec les enfants le prof
gaz mais c'est pas pour les enfants
turbulant maisas préparé deur non
nattaqueer pas rmond tout ce qu'il dit
est très sensé tranquille il
dit s'il vous plaît m parce qu'elle va
aller bientôt se coucher vous allez
arrêter le terrorisme une
bomcuse dans le monde de Valérie et de
Gill ce qui est légal c'est d'attendre
de se faire attaquer à angoulin par
exemple il y a des intrus qui sont
arrivés et qui ont brûlé quelqu'un avec
un fumigène quelqu'un aurait eu des gaz
lacrymogène il faut se battre avec
les non mais voilà dans un de violence
comme ça excuse-mo il faut les arm d'une
manière
comme il y a les lois alors on
att les gars c'est insupportable donc
vous laissez parler daniel Merci non
mais j'avais fini je dis dans
vot parce qu'il m'a chevauché mais
autrement enfin je dire pas une histoire
de loi en l'occurrence excuse-moi tu
viens tu ne dis que ça c'est légal c'est
légal c'est illégal il faut trouver les
bonnes armes il faut onattend pas les
bras croisés de faire j'ai envie
d'entendre j'ai envie d'entendre une
autre personne âgée Guillaume mais on
parle des attaques terroristes qui sont
évidemment tragique mais il y a pas que
ça il y a des agressions il y a des
violences au quotidien et c'est contre
ça qu'il faut lutter aussi aujourd'hui
et donc il faut instaurer des moyens de
dissuasion envers les élèves et je pense
qu'un élève quand il sait que le prof
est équipé de bomb Lam je
trouveéleaz quand j'étais à l'écolei
coup de
gaz je trouve que c'est facile de parler
à la place des prof de dire mais ça va
on autrement va te taper une classe de
15 ou 20 élèves qui qui veulent [__]
la merde et qui veulent s'en prendre à
toi physiquement ou verbalement au moins
tu as moyen de la justice la justice qui
doit s'occuperux et des petits cons qui
foutent le bordel c'est pas le prof qui
va sortir sa gaz larymogène et qui va
rentrer dans sa
voiture attends la petite de 30 ans qui
va qui va s'en prendre un mec de 14 ans
dans une élè dans une classe perturbée
c'est ce qu'il vient de dire tu la
gazes vous êtes fous franchement vous
êtes fous vous êtes fous n'allez pas
mettre des problèmes sur les profs les
profs ils ont pas besoin de ça ils ont
pas besoin c'est la justice qui doit
aider les
prof qu'est-ce que tu penses n'importe
quoi moi je pense que si on arrive pas à
tenir les gens faut bien se protéger et
puis ça va c'est c'est du gaz
lacrymogène ça veut dire que les gens
ils vont avoir peur parce que ça brûle
ça fait mal mais ça va pas tuer c'est
pas des opinell va tir dessus quand même
laiss la parler oui mais moi je veux
bien mais même tu prends de la gaz
acmogène si tu as une arme tu vas tirer
quand même les
gars Mo je peux dire j'ai pris de LAOG
je tire quand même hasard
[Applaudissements]
mais V hasard TR un truc moi au départ
j'étais pour et en entendant tout le
monde ici bizarrement je suis d'accord
avec crmon et G
ver que Valérie Mo mais c'est vrai que
je suis surtout d'accord avecM parce que
les arguments de Val chiant à mourir
mais je lesc justement je le
sais raison sur un truc ça va être
l'escalade plî le prof qui va gazer un
élève derrière ça va le père il va venir
le père va
venir il a raison il a raison sur un
truc c'est que en vrai il a dit un truc
et tu vois parce que tu vois il a boî
maîre chien et ben je te jure que c'est
vrai il dit pas que des conneries parce
que ce qu'il a dit au début je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec lui il dit déjà si
on en arrive là c'est les mecs c'est
n'importe quoi vous rendezte dans les
écoles dans les écoles maintenant ça
veut dire que doit on se pose la
questionquiper les profs de gaz ça veut
dire direon même plus capable par la
justice et par la police PV polici bien
on va pas les envoyer on va pas mettre
un policier on pas gazer quand il
mauvaise note on va pas le gazer quand
il qui dit R qui dit je t'aime beaucoup
r excuse-moi mais là tu dis une connerie
on tu je te dis on va pas mettre un
policier derrière ch élè sais combien ça
coûte tu sais tu sais aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je vais te dire aujourd'hui
les moyens les pauvres les pauvres
policiers ils ont des moyens mais
catastrophique aujourd'hui même si tu
mets un policier derrière et si tu dis
voilà le petit le petit trou du cul il a
cassé les carreaux il a cassé C il a
cassé ça on a mis un policier derrière
lui après il est sanctionné par la
justice non mais bien sûr après s'il est
sanctionné le policier il va être
content d'y aller mais le policier va
dire j'ai autre chose à [__] que
d'aller prendre un mec qui va faire 2
heures de garde à vue et qui va
ressortir alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait
donner des gaz à cro au prof ils vont
sortir les G mo je lui mets une claque
je dis range tamogène tout de suite
c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche oui c'est comme
ça tu croisécole dans les années 70 là
pensionnat chavour de
l'aorité s'il vous plat c'est une de mes
préfér RZ que moi j'entends ce que tu
dis Raymon effectivement ce serait bien
que l'école ça soit sanctuarisée mais
aujourd'hui en fait c'est plus le cas en
fait il y a 20 ans les profs faisaient
pas tuer il y a 20 ans les profs se
faisaient pas menacer par des Coutau
jeai fait moi c'est pas vrai
je j'ai menacé des profs moi ça existait
pas il y a 20
ans dites pas que ça existait pas il y a
20 ans va faire une classe de CPPN ans
les profs se faisaient pas intimider
quand ils apprenaient des certaines
parties du programme en histoire ou en
musique ou voilà il y a une réalité
d'une violence incroyable et je te
trouve très naïf évidemment enfin je
veux dire on va pas gazer
unlèaise moi je pense que on peut
essayer on peut l'encadrer on peut
tenter le truc inssécurité dans les
écoles nous on pas
concern
comm faisons rien tout va
bien de l'aualité en F de l'ité les
choses es ont évolué par exemple avant
dans dans les avions par exemple avant
avant le 11 septembre on avait le droit
de prendre beaucoup d'eau de prend
valise pas avoir de contrôle de sécurité
bon aujourd'hui la situation elle a
changé aujourd'hui ça n'est
pasempleève des trucs maintenant et to
tu c'est pas c'est pas vrai tu me fais
passer pour n'importe quoi j'étais pas
du
tout on a la chance d'avoir un
[Applaudissements]
lou mais non c'est pas une question de
Loub c'est juste que si vous mettez
comme il a dit si vous arrivez à mettre
de l'acmogène dans po des prof dans des
lyées qui
sonté et dans des cèges ené amuse-toi à
gazer d'abord vous allez mettre le prof
en galère j'en suis sûr parce qu'ils
vont l'attendre à 3 dans le parking et
le lendemain c'est mort d'un prof qui
s'est fait
cule c'est la justice qui doit s'em ça
Ren à voir l'impuissanceance
pay VE
d'écheentend
c'est un Ave d'échec de dire la seule
solution c'est de mettre un pement je le
Red sur une jambe de bois en
don le disant si vous avez un problème
ou un incident vous le
règlerez
faend l'école mais différ
moi je préfère 100 fois votre copine non
mais c'est pardon mais excuse-moi
Valérie Raymond mais vous êtes où en
fait vous croyez que vous êtes dans la
vraie vie de quoi mais aujourd'hui par
exemple on a même pas osé appeler
l'école Samuel Patti en hommage
tellement les gens ils ont peur donc ça
veut dire ça veut dire que le monde a
changéord je dit
Conner gars si vous parlez en même temps
vous sortez donc laissez Galine parler
s'il vous plaît merci trve je trouve que
le monde a changé je trouve que vous
êtes extrêmement on va dire timide
extrêmement na
il
tu est d'accord personnevisage de gaz
personne MAA
comportement at à la personne toi
maintenant comment tu te
défendsver le mec qui vient faire une
dingerie dans une école avec un couteau
une arme tu lui sors un
[Musique]
gaziss vousêes déjà pris un coup de gaz
lamogè et vous êtes tombé Mor comme des
[Rires]
mouches
[Applaudissements]
c'est Bonell c'est bon ça bouge plus oui
ce que j'aime pas ce que j'aime pas dans
le poadon c'est que tu te couches
d'office devant les les délinquants et
les racaes bien sûr que
si quoi mais bien sûr que oui tu peux
pas dire ah toute façon il va faire une
dinguerie le lendemain il va venir nous
frapper et puis va faire un attentat et
cetera commençons par réinstaurer
l'autorité et on parle pas forcément
encore une fois d'attentat combien rmon
combien de fois on a vu des élèves juste
qui vont voir les profs qui font des
têtes contre têtes juste ça c'est un
manque de respect ultime alors ok il y a
pas momme coup de gaz Lamo terminé merci
au revoir désolé tu peux pas te coucher
d'office devant les les élèves et les
racailles pardon et le donner tous les
droits parce que ils sont dangereux
c'est n'importe
quoi Guillaume j'ad mais écoute pas au
début au début de ce que j'ai dit j'ai
dit c'est pas au prof de mettre en
galère c'est la
justice toi tu me dis toi tu me dis s'il
y a un mec qui se met tête tête avec un
prof attends tu m'as dit je t'écouté tu
m'as dit si le mec il se met tête tête
avec le prof le prof sort un coup de gaz
il rentre l'élève qu'est-ce qu'il fait h
il a les yeux complètement éés il
retourne s'assoir contrôle d'histoire ça
tu
trquer ouis tu veux parler oui s'il te
plaît oui
c'est mais tu tu parles de la justice la
justice elle est là pour agir une fois
que le dégât a été causé c'est pas en
préventif voilà en
préventif pardon pard le principe c'est
de de fournir c'est pas obligatoire de
fournir des gaz lacrimau au au aux
professeurs qui en veulent il le veulent
mais certains veulent ils sont tous
levés ils ont manifesté pour qu'ils en
voulaient pas je crois pas non donc
voilà certainement qu'on veulent on leur
donne la possibilité ça leur évitera
parfois de se faire braquer et cetera un
coup de gaz lacrymogène si ça va pas le
lendemain c'est un coup de Gourdon de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gourd voilà elle a raison c'est
l'escalade ah oui c'est l'escalade et
excuse-moi tuas un lac
là je CIS pas
non non mais c'est irresponsable de dire
oui à l'image de ce que vient de dire
Jean-Michel d'abord la lacricrimo et
après ça va être quoi le revolver ça
vaêre on peut pas armer les professeurs
et tu dis rien pour les professeurs qui
se font
défoncer juste tu as fait PIP
des non mais c'est du délire cy c'est un
qui joue
ilut
il vol la LAM et dans ces CASL c'est eu
qui vont être gaz tout de
suite tpectateurs vous PL
[Applaudissements]
mer moi j'étais dans les
ou il je suis heureux dans les oui parce
que au début j'étais dans les non [__]
j'ai pas et puis j'aime pas être contre
le allez faites-le j'aime pas être cont
le public a toujours raisonit qu'est-ce
qu'il veut non mais du coup c'est bon on
le débat tu vas pas tarder à me faire
chier euh